number five i wouldn't i would say it's
inappropriate not texas but yeah
scarlett johansson now were you able to
wear
undergarments you're like the fifth
person that's out no because what is
going on ms johansen is no stranger to
sexist interview questions and they came
in on a seemingly constant basis while
she did press for her role in the
avengers movies for instance there was
this press conference in new york i
think was sexist i think it was sexist
to have her do that role
because honestly like i swear to god i
swear to god if i am ever in trouble
okay this is this is controversial okay
so buckle up
if i'm ever getting robbed and they send
me a female police officer
what is she gonna do
what does she especially in the uk you
guys don't even have guns here
like in the us at least she's got a gun
you know that's better but like even so
if she's like a five five girl they
could just take it
i'm not even a big movie person i i
watched this movie but it was so long
ago but if i remember correctly
yeah no no no no
but we'll see robert downey jr was asked
about character development and
johansson was asked about her fitness
regime and to scarlet to getting into
the shape of black widow did you have
anything special to do in terms of the
diet
like you have to eat some specific food
or that sort of thing instead of
responding she questioned why her
co-stars got the interesting questions
yeah well
not trying to be rude robert downey jr
is a better actor than you
half the reason you're here is cause
you're hot
but you're not complaining about getting
opportunity because you're hot but then
when someone comments on you being hot
boo hoo cry me ruff
please
well she was only asked about her figure
like how come you get like the really
interesting like existential question
and i get the like rabbit food question
similarly she seems to be asked quite
often about the undergarments she wears
under her black widow costume does the
hulk have ripped up cgi tidy whities
under his ripped up cgi pants we may
never know is it inappropriate to ask
somebody what kind of underpants they
were i didn't ask you what kind you just
asked me if i was wearing any number
four rowan blanchard
i've been waiting
for a day like this to come the girl
meets world star had the perfect
response when a red carpet reporter once
asked her if she had any dieting tips
for other teenage girls blanchard who
was only 13 at the time told elle that
she questioned whether they'd ever ask
about dieting tips for teenage boys i
kind of feel strongly about everything
especially anything that relates to
girl hood and being a girl she went on
to assert that she does not diet i mean
they might ask that if the dude's jack
and that if she has one food related tip
for fans it's that quote if you don't
order fries you'll probably be mad
poignant and true our image has always
been kind of painted by men or for men
so why is she this young spewing this
nonsense she's supposed to be a kid when
you see it she's not supposed to hate
men at freaking 13 years old girls take
a selfie in public and she's literally
in control of how she wants to look and
how she wants to be portrayed there's
such power in that number three there's
power in taking a selfie oh my god
hathaway
after having a much reported upon
wardrobe malfunction at the premiere of
her 2012 film les miserables anne
hathaway sat down with the today show's
matt lauer he jumped right into things
by asking her what was the lesson
learned i was very sad that we live in
an age when someone takes a picture of
another person in a vulnerable moment
and rather than delete it and do the
decent thing sells it rather than
allowing herself to be blamed she turned
his question around and put the blame
squarely on the photographer and the
population who will pay for such an
image and i'm sorry that we live in a
culture
that commodifies sexuality of unwilling
participants which brings us back to les
mis because that's what my character is
she is
someone who is forced to sell sex to
benefit her child because she has
nothing and there's no social safety net
stop it stop it
there are single fathers out there and
they have to get a job you are not
forced to be a hooker
oh my
stop it
up
you're good
look i understand there's hard times i
understand there's people that have been
sit in situations where they have to
make decisions that i will never have to
make
but nobody forced you to be a hooker no
no one four should be hooker
anyways
and i
yeah so um
unfortunately this wasn't the only time
hathaway was faced with sexist questions
while doing press for the dark knight
rises anne hathaway was asked about her
feline fitness routine what is the
feline fitness regime
um a lot it's it's it's all the boring
stuff that no one ever wants to do is
just watch what you eat and get yourself
to the gym after trying to deflect the
line of questioning away from her
catwoman costume and her body she
finally had enough of his persistence
and she turned the question right back
on him any particular workout trying to
lose weight well what's what's the deal
man you look great no no no no no
seriously that we have to talk about
this what what do you want are you
trying to fit into a cat suit number two
ariana grande
the side to side singer was not going to
take any gendered questions when she was
participating in a radio interview in
the mid-2010s the hosts of the show who
all happen to be male asked her if she
had to give up one thing her cell phone
or her makeup which it would be if you
could use makeup or your phone one last
time which one would you pick
your makeup or your phone is this what
you think girls have trouble choosing
yeah yeah absolutely she responded right
away by letting them know she thought
the question was a sexist one ladies
learn
listen and remember
as the interview went on however they
continued to put an emphasis on things
that girls do and she eventually had to
lay down the bruh i mean
guys some stereotypes exist for a reason
i'm a girl i'm addicted to my phone half
the [ __ ] i know are addicted to their
phones can we just stop playing
can we stop playing blessing blessing
he's camera shy he's not gonna be on
camera
your girl always on her phone
like it just is what it is yeah there's
a lot of dudes that are addicted to
video games
you know you know someone a dude that's
addicted to video games
yeah yeah does it make me sexist no no
so why why do these like why
she's offended over that it's true um
okay a lot for them
you need a little brushing up on
equality over here
come on
before we continue be sure to subscribe
to our channel and ring the bell to get
notified about our latest videos you
have the option to be notified for
occasional videos or all of them if
you're on your phone make sure you go
into your settings and switch on
notifications
number one helen mirren do you think i
mean you are in quotes a serious actress
um you know yeah
today feminism is no longer a dirty word
and many stars proudly claim it in 1975
however speaking up about issues of
sexism was much more difficult and not
always as well received i you find in
fact that this what could be best
described as your equipment in fact
hinders you perhaps in that pursuit
i'd like you to explain what you mean by
my queen helen mirren appeared on
michael parkinson's iconic chat show
early in her career and found herself
cornered into an uncomfortable
conversation
serious actress because serious
actresses can't have
big bosoms is that what you mean
well i think that they might sort of
detract from the performance if you know
what i mean parkinson seemed to focus on
her body rather than her abilities
if you don't want to be okay
stop it
you know you if you want to go somewhere
where you won't
be have your looks be the focus go be an
engineer
go lay bricks
why do women that you go put yourself on
a screen where they're looking for
beautiful women
and then complain that people notice
that you're beautiful go lay bricks
go
press and while the clip is
uncomfortable to watch seeing miron own
him is totally worth it what a crummy
performance if people are obsessed with
the size of your bosom or anything else
i would hope that
the performance and the play and the
living relationship
between all the people on stage and all
the people in the audience overcome such
nasty it didn't because that's still the
question that he asked as many of you
know i was just banned on tick-tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible